muchas gracias
señor presidente
señor el secretario general y
distinguidos miembros del consejo de
seguridad y otros miembros de esta
reunión gracias por esta oportunidad
estoy seguro que todos los
representantes de los miembros de
naciones unidas me escucharán ayer
regresé de la ciudad de muchas
recientemente liberada de las tropas
rusas no lejos de quiere entonces
no hay un solo crimen que ellos no hayan
cometido ya los fueron tropas rusas
mataron a cualquier persona que haya
servido a nuestro país
andrew ha matado mujeres afuera de sus
casas como simplemente trataban de
llamar a alguien mataron a familias
enteras adultos niños y trataron de
quemar los cuerpos me dirijo a ustedes
en nombre
de las personas y para honrar la memoria
de los muertos
honrando la memoria de todos los civiles
que han muerto asesinados con un tiro en
la cabeza después de haber sido
torturados algunos torturados en la
calle otros lanzados en pozos
fueron asesinados en sus apartamentos en
sus casas con la explosión de granadas
fueron civiles que fueron aplastados por
tanques conley en sus carros en medio de
la ruta simplemente por placer
les cortaron las gargantas los miembros
y mujeres asesinadas en frente de los
niños les sacaron las lenguas
simplemente porque no escucharon lo que
querían escuchar de ellos entonces esto
no es diferente de otros terroristas
como dais que han ocupado otros
territorios y aquí está siendo realizado
por un miembro del consejo de seguridad
de naciones unidas
que está destruyendo las fronteras y se
está tomando el derecho de
los países que son independientes
continúan la política de destrucción
la diversidad étnica y religiosa traen
guerra y tratan de borrarlos de una
manera
que termina matando los civiles comunes
y corrientes en el país donde han
llevado sus tropas y donde dejan
cosas comunes
ellos buscan exportar a estos otros
países a través de un sistema de
propaganda y de corrupción política
han generado una crisis
alimenticia global que podría generar
hambrunas en asia y en áfrica y también
en otros países
generando un nuevo caos político en
muchos países donde están destruyendo la
seguridad entonces
lo que necesita garantizar el consejo de
seguridad no está ahí aunque existe el
consejo de seguridad
[Música]
entonces dónde está la paz
dónde están esas garantías que las
naciones unidas necesita garantizar es
obvio que la situación
porque debe
y acabar con
estos agresores simplemente no pueden
funcionar
de manera efectiva ya se ha visto lo que
es el ejército de muchos
mientras estaba en la ciudad bajo su
ocupación pero el mundo aún tiene que
ver lo que han hecho en otras ciudades
ocupadas y otras regiones de nuestro
país
la geografía puede ser diferente pero la
crueldad es la misma los crímenes son
los mismos y la rendición de cuentas
debe ser inevitable señoras y señores me
gustaría recordarles del artículo 1 del
capítulo 1 de la carta de naciones
unidas cuál es el propósito de nuestra
organización
el propósito es mantener la paz y
asegurarnos que la paz se respete y
ahora la carta de naciones unidas está
siendo violada desde su artículo 1
entonces cuál es el punto de cualquier
de los demás artículos como resultado de
las acciones de rusia y en nuestro país
en ucrania en los crímenes de guerra más
terribles de todos los tiempos estamos
viendo las ahora desde el principio de
la segunda guerra mundial y se están
cometiendo en este instante las tropas
están destruyendo ciudades ucranianas
las están dejando en cenizas con
artillería y ataques aéreos están
bloqueando a las ciudades generando
hambrunas masivas
dando atacando civiles que están
tratando de escapar de las hostilidades
incluso de manera deliberada han atacado
refugios y están deliberadamente creando
condiciones en los territorios ocupados
temporalmente
para que mueran civiles en esas zonas
las masacres se mucha es solamente una
de muchas muchos ejemplos de lo que los
ocupantes han hecho en nuestra tierra en
los últimos 41 días y hay muchos más
lugares similares donde el mundo aún
tendrá que saber la verdad mariupol
harker chernóbil
blanca y otras decenas de comunidades
dónde
cada uno de ellos es similares a buzzi
yo sé y ustedes también saben
perfectamente lo que los representantes
de rusia van a decir en respuesta a las
acusaciones de estos crímenes ellos han
dicho esto muchas veces y el más
significativo fue después de
cuando tumbaron el avión y demás desert
lines en el donbass o también con la
guerra en siria ellos van a culpar a
cualquier otra persona para justificar
sus propias acciones van a decir que
hay diferentes versiones y que es
imposible establecer cuál de esas
versiones es la verdadera ellos dirán
que los cuerpos de esos de esos civiles
fueron lanzados y que todo esto fue
significado pero estamos en 2022 tenemos
evidencia concluyente imágenes
satelitales y podemos llevar a cabo
investigaciones a fondo sobre lo que nos
interesa maximizar el acceso para los
periodistas en la maximizar la
cooperación con las instituciones
internacionales y también con la corte
penal internacional para que se rindan
cuentas de manera contundente y estoy
seguro que cualquier estado de naciones
unidas- estará interesado en esto porque
para poder castigar de una vez por todas
a aquellos que se consideran
privilegiados y
creen que pueden salirse con la suya
entonces
otros potenciales criminales de guerra
en el mundo como serán castigados si el
más grande de todos
es castigado entonces todos los demás
serán castigados porque ucrania
porque hay rusia ucrania les diré por
qué
el liderazgo de rusia 100 se sienten
como colonizadores de tiempos antiguos
quieren nuestra riqueza nuestro pueblo
ya han deportado a cientos de miles
a su territorio han secuestrado a más de
2.000 niños y continúan haciéndolo para
llevarlos a su territorio quieren
convertir a ucrania en esclavos
silenciosos y están robando abiertamente
en las ciudades y en los pueblos que han
capturado
es un robo a gran escala se están
robando la comida
los aretes de oro
incluso cuando están cubiertos de sangre
estamos aquí ante un estado que está
convirtiendo el veto no alcanzaba
seguridad en un derecho a la muerte y
esto amenaza la arquitectura de la paz
de la seguridad internacional y están
destruyendo todo lo que pueden entonces
si esto continúa
los países
solo podrán contar con el poder de sus
propias armas para asegurar su seguridad
y no
en la ley internacional no podrán
confiar en las instituciones
internacionales y naciones unidas
podría ser simplemente cerrada y
creen que el momento de la ley
internacional se ha terminado y su
respuesta es no entonces tienen que
actuar inmediatamente
en la carta de naciones unidas debe ser
restaurada inmediatamente el sistema
debe ser reformado inmediatamente para
que el veto no sea sinónimo de un
derecho a la muerte
existe una representación del consejo de
todas regiones del mundo y se debe traer
la paz inmediatamente y se necesita
determinación
la masacre de siria a somalia afganistán
yemen libia eso debió haberse detenido
hace mucho tiempo para decirles la
verdad si la tiranía hubiese alguna vez
recibido esta respuesta ante la guerra
que nosotros hemos logrado habría dejado
de existir y la paz se habría
garantizado y el mundo habría cambiado
con seguridad entonces tal vez no habría
guerra en mi país de nuevo en contra de
nuestra gente en contra de los
ucranianos en contra
de nuestros ciudadanos pero el mundo
miro observo y
no quiso hacer nada tras la ocupación de
crimea la guerra contra georgia
o la toma de transnistria en moldavia y
pero las bases para otros conflictos
como detenerlos
a bases militares rusas y aquellos que
les dan órdenes deben ser llevados ante
la justicia de manera inmediata por
crímenes de guerra en ucrania y
cualquiera que haya recibido estas
órdenes y que las haya realizado matando
a nuestra gente
debe ser llevado ante un tribunal
algo similar a los tribunales de
nuremberg
y quiero recordar los diplomáticos que
y
no se escapan de la condena por los
crímenes después de la segunda guerra
mundial y quiero recordar que tampoco
estos se quedaron sin respuesta en
ninguno de ellos escapó pero lo
principal hoy es que es momento de
transformar el sistema
de las naciones unidas y por ende
propongo
llevar a cabo una conferencia global
para que podemos hacerlo aquí en kiev
para poder determinar cómo podemos
reformar el sistema de seguridad global
cómo vamos a poder contar o establecer
las garantías del reconocimiento de las
fronteras y de la integridad de los
estados y de los países cómo podemos
establecer las reglas de la ley
internacional humanitaria y
es cierto que los realizados san
francisco en el 45 después de una
organización internacional no
se ha logrado y es importante es
imposible lograrlo sin reformas y por
ende debemos hacer todo lo necesario
para
todo lo que está en nuestro poder para
pasarle a la próxima generación
en unas naciones unidas- efectivas que
puedan responder de manera efectiva a
estas amenazas de seguridad en evitar
las agresiones y llevar y forzar a los
agresores a entrar de nuevo la paz si
los principios de la paz están siendo
violados y no puede haber ninguna
excepción de privilegios todo el mundo
debe ser igual todos los participantes
de las relaciones internacionales
dependiente independiente de su
geografía de su poder económico
o de sus
ambiciones individuales el poder de la
paz debe convertirse en dominante el
poder de la justicia
es lo que la humanidad siempre ha soñado
ucrania está dispuesta a dar la
plataforma para algunas de las oficinas
de este nuevo sistema similar a la
oficina de ginebra que tenga que ver con
derechos humanos o la de nairobi sobre
la protección medioambiental y uno
oficina que pueda esforzarse en mantener
la paz y quisiera recordarle de nuestra
misión de paz en afganistán cuando
nosotros los ucranianos
evacuamos de ese país
a más de 1000 personas
con nuestros propios medios fue una fase
muy difícil y ucrania él llegó para
ayudar trajimos a personas de diferentes
nacionalidades de grupos étnicos
diferentes edades ciudadanos afganos
también de canadá eeuu y países europeos
nosotros no miramos quién necesitaba
ayuda
o si era uno de nosotros o era alguien
más simplemente nos ayudamos salvamos a
todos los que pudimos cada vez que
existía esa necesidad
podrían tener la seguridad de que esa
ayuda vendría de que el mundo sería
claramente más seguro y por ende ucrania
tiene el derecho moral de proponer una
reforma del sistema de seguridad mundial
y hemos probado que no estamos en
solamente los momentos parisi sino
también en los momentos oscuros y se
necesitan las decisiones del consejo de
seguridad para la paz en ucrania y sí no
saben cómo tomar estas decisiones pueden
hacer dos cosas
sacar a rusia como agresor
y como fuente de la guerra para que no
pueda bloquear las decisiones sobre sus
propias agresiones y su propia guerra y
hacer todo lo que podamos
hacer para establecer la paz o la otra
opción es mostrar
cómo podemos reformar o cambiar
y trabajar por la paz y si no existe
alternativa y no existen opciones
entonces la siguiente opción sería
disolver el consejo simplemente y pueden
admitir que si no hay nada que ustedes
puedan hacer además de conversar pues
necesitamos paz y ucrania necesita paz
europa necesita paz y el mundo necesita
paz y finalmente
les pediría amablemente
a todos los que han visto este vídeo
por favor denos un minuto más de su
tiempo
y
tú
como para mostrar como un solo país
puede violar esos derechos y este es el
resultado de no haber sido castigado en
el pasado y por favor vea en este vídeo
porque es importante es imposible que
todo el mundo venga aquí para observarlo
con sus propios ojos y por ende les pido
que miren este vídeo muchas gracias